there's nothing subtle about Indiana
Jones fighting Nazis but the team behind
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
left one line in the movie that has a
history you wouldn't expect after
Raiders of the Lost Ark and the Last
Crusade director Steven Spielberg chose
not to use history's most despicable
fascists as the antagonist for the
fourth Indie movie Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull however franchise newcomer
James Mangold opted to bring them back
once more for Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny this time around the villains
feel significantly more threatening
which is almost certainly a reflection
of the disturbing rise in neo-nazism
across the globe Ghana the cartoonish
face melting villains of Raiders of the
Lost Ark it would feel just at home in
an episode of Hogan's Heroes in nested
Mangold presents us with a foe more
tangible and mass Mickelson's Jurgen
Vale a brilliant scientist has flew into
mythology as he is in propaganda and
manipulation the film even goes so far
as the megavala an American asset
calling clear attention to Operation
Paperclip the U.S intelligence
initiative the saw Nazi scientist
brought to America to work on advanced
technology during the Cold War my
memories
are you still a Nazi there is nothing
vital satirical about the Nazis and dial
of Destiny a fact emphasized firmly yet
subtly with a line of dialogue for
Mickelson's Valor towards the end of the
film with his historically revisionist
goals in his grasp he turns yesterday
belongs to us this line seems to be a
carefully chosen reference that
solidifies vale's file motivations by
alluding to an enduring and complicated
1960s song the phrase yesterday belongs
to us is eerily close to the title of
the fictionist Nazi Anthem tomorrow
belongs to me written by Jewish
composers John kander and Fred ebb for
their groundbreaking theatrical work
Cabaret originally premiering in 1966
three years before the events of dial of
Destiny Cabaret is a popular and
staunchly anti-fascist Musical that
Chronicles the Insidious rise of the
Nazi party in Germany from several
different perspectives the story
primarily follows a politically
ambivalent American writer who finds
himself intimately entangled with his
pushy English students Jewish neighbors
and the staff of a queer nightclub in
1930s Berlin Cabaret has often been
described as intentionally deceptive
especially in its tone first appearing
as a Walker's Lee's seductive dramedy
only to reveal itself as a devastating
tragedy this deceptiveness is best
encapsulated by the song Tomorrow
belongs to me which is heard twice in
the show's First Act in most Productions
it is initially sung by either a young
boy or a waiter it's pastoral lyrics and
dreamlike Melody painting an innocent
optimistic image for the unassuming
audience it is until later that it
becomes clear usually through a creeping
build of instruments the sudden
appearance of nationalist emblems on set
or a growing Ensemble of singer's eerily
large in number that the song is a
fascist Anthem meant to inspire a
violent nationalistic Uprising valor's
apparent allusion to the song in dial of
Destiny also eerily mimics away it has
been misappropriated over the years
sadly tomorrow belongs to me was so
effective as a fictional fascist Anthem
that it was adopted by real life flashes
across the world one of the first
organizations to use a song from
malevolent purposes was a national
socialist League an American Neo-Nazi
group composed entirely of gay men
however the song's apparent reference in
dial of Destiny goes beyond merely
evolving the Nazis of Raiders of the
Lost Ark from hapless soldiers into a
more Insidious contingent of white
supremacists there's a clear
Consciousness within The Narrative of
dial of destiny that Nazis are no longer
a historical foe long since defeated but
an emerging and ever-growing threat in
the same vein tomorrow belongs to me is
as relevant today as it was in the 1960s
with notable contemporary proponents of
Nazi ideology publicly appropriating the
song within the last few years from its
use of Nazis to his bizarre time travel
plus dial of Destiny is consistently
concerned with how history impacts the
future a concern that lends itself quite
well to an Indiana Jones Adventure it's
likely allusion to tomorrow belongs to
me it's just one of the many ways to
film colors its historical antagonist
with a chilling events in the modern day